DEREK DOWNEY: Hi, everyone.
I'm Derek Downey, a
developer advocate at Google.
I want to show
you how easy it is
to get started developing on
Cloud Spanner, Google's highly
scalable relational database.
Over the course
of several videos,
you will learn how to set up
your development environment
to work with Spanner.
You will see how to set up a
Spanner instance and database,
as well as details on
defining your schema.
And finally, you will
learn how to read and write
your data to Spanner instances
using standard SQL transactions
and Spanner mutations.
In this first quick
start video, I
will connect a simple
Java application
to the Cloud Spanner emulator.
The emulator allows you to
mimic Spanner functionality
on your local
development machine.
This quick start
will also highlight
creating the Spanner
schema, as well as reading
and writing data into Spanner.
This won't be a typical
"Hello, world" application.
I'm going to build the start
of a simple banking app.
This app will allow customers
to create an account and log in.
I will use the
JetBrains IntelliJ IDE.
If you don't use
IntelliJ, don't worry.
You can still get
started quickly
using your IDE of choice.
So let's get to it.
I will be connecting into
Cloud Spanner in this banking
application.
However, since I'm
just getting started,
I want to use the Cloud Spanner
emulator, which runs directly
on my machine.
The Spanner emulator
mimics the functionality
of a Spanner instance.
I can switch to a
real Spanner instance
later when this application
is ready for collaboration.
So the first thing I need to do
is install the gcloud command
line tool.
There are instructions
in the video description
of how to do this for
your operating system.
But once gcloud is installed, I
will create a new configuration
for our banking project.
The project I
specified doesn't have
to be a real Google Cloud
project, since the emulator
won't validate it.
But this is needed
for our application
to use Spanner's Java library.
All right.
Now I will start the emulator
as a background task.
Once that is running, I will
create an instance called
"banking."
This uses the emulator
configuration,
since we are using the emulator.
Now, we have our Spanner
instance running.
But it doesn't do any good
without a database and schema.
I could create this
in the command line.
But I want to make sure
this step is repeatable,
since I will eventually
move this to a real Spanner
instance.
So I have created a file that
has the DDL commands to create
the database and my table.
For now, I am creating
a single customers table
that stores some basic
information about the user,
including a username and
password for authentication.
Once I've provided the instance
and database configuration,
I can run the file from my IDE.
Great.
Now I have the database
defined with a customers table.
One neat thing is the ability
to explore the database directly
within the IDE.
To do this in IntelliJ, I need
to add the Cloud Spanner data
source from the database tools.
With that added, I need
to populate the instance
and project information.
Since I'm using the
emulator, I don't
need to authenticate
to the instance.
But I will need the URL to
connect to the local host
on port 9010, which is the
default for the emulator.
I'll also pass in the autoconfig
emulator equals true parameter.
Perfect.
I could see my schema
that I created previously.
I'm almost done.
To finish up, I want
to write some data
and then read it back.
I'll need to be able to have
users sign up to my bank.
And I do that in my
createCustomer function.
I am using standard SQL within
a read/write transaction
to insert a user into the
customers table based on input
provided to the application.
Once a customer is signed up,
then they will need to log in.
The login function will
issue a read from Spanner
to validate the
user's credentials.
With the ability for customers
to sign up and log in,
I am ready to run
the application.
I tell the application
that I want to sign up.
And then I provide
my information.
Once my customer is
created, I can log in
by providing username
and password.
And I've successfully logged in.
Back in my editor, I
can see the new user
that was entered
from the application.
Fantastic.
It didn't take long to get my
simple application interacting
with the Spanner emulator.
This is great for getting
my feet wet with Spanner.
But soon, I will
need other developers
to collaborate on
this application.
And for that, I will need
to create an actual Spanner
instance.
In the next video,
I will go over
what a Spanner instance is
and the different options
for creating one.
In the meantime, go ahead and
try out the Spanner emulator
for yourself.
And let us know in the
comments your experience.
[MUSIC PLAYING]